Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday.
It's actually Monday, but tomorrow is a travel day.
Oh hi there, half-finished 3 AM room service dinner.
Let's look outside and see where I am.
Apparently, I'm in Paris! Awesome.
Why is there a pool? Also, why is Italy across the street?
Ugh! I'm in Las Vegas, aren't I?
Hank, as you well know, I have been to Las Vegas once before for my bachelor party
which we called "Nerds Do Vegas."
Hank, I don't know if you've seen the movie "The Hangover" but as I'm sure you remember,
my bachelor party was the exact opposite of that.
However Hank, when we were in Las Vegas, you did gamble.
Hold on, I gotta go buy a razor. Walk with me. I should put on pants first.
As I recall, you played a game called Casino War. You walked up to the table,
placed the minimum bet, won the bet, walked away, and retired from gambling a winner.
But Hank, because I am the naughty brother, I am a much more aggressive gambler.
So Hank last night I sat down at the roulette table at about 11 PM with one hundred dollars.
Three hours later, I left the casino with: one hundred TEN dollars.
Now Hank, I don't like to brag but I am an extremely good roulette player.
What makes me so good? Well for one thing I have a passion for the game
because I love tiny balls.
That's why I love golf, Rube Goldberg machines, and Jezzball.
What else has tiny balls?
"What do you do for a living, John Green?"
Well, I sit around in hotel rooms and try to think of things with tiny balls.
Mmm, you are delicious, last night's French fries.
Anyway Hank, here's the key to playing roulette.
You have to understand that, over time, you're going to lose all your money.
I don't mean you're sometimes going to lose all your money,
I mean you're ALWAYS going to lose ALL of your money.
So the key to success is to bet as little as possible as infrequently as possible
and every time the cocktail waitress asks if you want a Sprite, you say yes.
And since the Sprites are "free," that way even if you lose, you still got four Sprites for your $100.
Ugghhhhhhhh. Of course, this strategy also works for drinks that aren't Sprite.
Ultimately for me Hank, gambling isn't so much a reminder of probability as it is a reminder of perspective.
I mean, walking home from the casino last night, I felt like I'd had a pretty successful evening.
I met some Canadian chaps, I got to watch one of my beloved tiny balls spin around a wheel for three hours...
...plus I got quite a few free drinks, and I won ten whole dollars!
But Hank, here in the cold gray light of the morning after, those free drinks just feel like a
slight headache and liquid calories I'm gonna have to walk off on the treadmill desk
and I can't help but feel like for all my labor last night,
I made less than $4 per hour.
In short Hank, I may be the older brother but when it comes to gambling and also so much else,
you are the wiser one. Okay I have to go give a speech to people who work at colleges.
High school nerdfighters, I will definitely tell these people to accept ALL of you to ALL of the colleges.
Hank, I will see you on Friday!
(dying sounds)
P.S. Hank, airport, grey speckled walls, etc.,
That video was recorded before Hurricane Sandy came ashore and I just wanted to say:
Although I realize that most nerdfighters currently without power
aren't spending their cell batteries, like, watching YouTube, stay safe.
Also, bitterballen! Tiny delicious balls. And Dippin' Dots.